et nous sommes nous avec jean lespert
chercheur associé à la fondation
d'études pour le moyen-orient bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
l'on vient d'entendre donc le président
le président russe vladimir poutine qui
s'entretient donc en ce moment même avec
son homologue turc recep tayyip erdogan
s'était donc juste avant leur entretien
à huis clos
ce sommet avait été initialement proposé
par ankara avec angela merkel emmanuel
macron ce qui avait été ce qui n'a pas
été acceptée c'est finalement une
réunion bilatérale qui se déroule à
moscou
qu'est-ce que cela dit de la position de
la turquie aujourd'hui la turquie donc a
fait appel à à l'europe n'est ce pas
encore récemment avec bon une forme un
peu agressive en lâchant les une partie
des migrants
mais si on regarde la carte on voit
quand même que la syrie est un univers
arabe et donc il y existe une ligue
arabe à laquelle la turquie et
observateurs elle n'a pas activé ce une
rencontre au niveau de ligue arabe elle
n'a pas non plus active et non en compte
au niveau de la conférence coopération
islamique
elle a rappelé très bien puisque la
syrie aussi on fait partie bien qu'elle
est suspendu donc elle se tourne vers
l'europe
et ça c'est important de voir que
l'europe reste à un partenaire
économique
un partenaire militaire vis-à-vis de
l'otan est essentiel et donc les
confient les tensions qui ont lieu
actuellement chili sont plutôt du
ressort de la russie et de la turquie en
face à face donc pour résoudre cette
tension en face à face il logique dans
un premier temps et bien des rencontres
bilatérales des lieux la crainte d'une
confrontation directe entre les forces
turques et les forces russes est calé
fondé l'objectif aujourd'hui de cette
rencontre à moscou c'est d'éviter un
conflit ouvert il s'agit de trouver un
équilibre quel équilibre est possible
selon vous a écouté je pense qu'il est
tout à fait possible effectivement qu'il
y a
un de décomplexion comme on dit en
termes militaro diplomatique pour que
les deux puissances puissent se parler
et donc éviter des bombardements où il y
aurait effectivement présence de troupes
de l'inde un côté ou de l'autre voiture
que soit soit russe donc cela existe il
ya des liens de décomplexion entre la
russie et israël il ya des liens des
complications entre la russie et les
etats unis toujours au sujet de la syrie
donc il est important que ces liens
puissent être établies de façon à
établir dans un deuxième temps à cesser
le feu
car ce que c'est dans le cadre de ce
c'est le feu que effectivement l'europe
pourra intervenir soit d'un point de vue
humanitaire soit d'un point de vue
diplomatique parce que c'est là je crois
aussi un apport essentiel de la
collaboration entre la turquie et
l'europe c'est d'arriver à un traitement
de la crise humanitaire sur le sol
syrien est ce que vous pensez que le
président turc peut céder du terrain et
mettre fin notamment à ses manoeuvres
dans la région de lille disons que qui
déclenche le feu c'est donc apparemment
ce sont les troupes syriennes qui ont
qui sont dans la reconquête de terrain
alors un terrain qui avait été gelé à
faut pas oublier que les trois
puissances intervenante à savoir la
turquie l'iran et la russie ont des buts
de guerre différent donc la russie veut
le maintien du régime
la turquie ne s'est jamais caché qu'elle
souhaite le départ de bachar el-assad et
l'iran souhaite s'installer en syrie
donc on a des buts de guerre différent
et quand vous avez des buts de guerre
différent vous avez forcément des buts
de paix différend concernant la répu la
turque est ce qu'elle n'est pas un peu
isolé aujourd'hui sur la scène
internationale vis-à-vis de l'otan
qu'elle a sollicité son succès vis-à-vis
de l'union européen de l'union
européenne à qui elle fait
en face de laquelle elle brandit la
menace de la crise migratoire son succès
aussi finalement union européenne ne
sais pas quel est votre sentiment sur la
position aujourd'hui la turquie
géopolitique j'essaie de ne pas avoir le
sentiment que c'est d'avoir des analyses
et donc que l'analyse me dis que qu'ont
déclaré les membres de l'otan récemment
et bien que il était prêt à mettre à
disposition de la turquie des missiles
patriot quand il fait en réalité ils ont
aussi mis à disposition des awacs et à
dire des avions de reconnaissance à de
défense aérienne dont qui vont aider la
turquie à contrôler le ciel au-dessus de
la syrie de façon à éviter
effectivement toute interférence soit
d'avion de rue ce soit de missiles
syriens
donc il y a vraiment une coopération une
contribution de le temps et quand il ya
des tensions avec les états unis
les militaires américains ont toujours
dit à la turquie est un partenaire
essentiel de l'otan n'oublions pas que
la turquie est membre de l'otan depuis
c'est à dire trois ans avant l'arrivée
de l'allemagne de l'ouest
à l'époque dans l'alliance d'envoyer ou
les racines sont très anciennes et les
rapports entre militaires américains et
militaires de l'otan sont à son ex et
donc il faut faire la différence entre
le politique je dirais le politique
hertzog anne et puis la politique turque
sur le long terme
la rencontre à moscou et est toujours en
cours entre le président turc est et le
président russe
on imagine qu'il est question aussi de
l'accord de sotchi de 2018 est ce qu'il
est complètement caduque aujourd'hui
m'écouter il y avait cet appui sur des
points
12 bastion à turow tour d'idleb donc
ceux qui sont au sud il lab sont en
difficulté donc que va-t-il en ressortir
après cet entretien donc ça c'est la
grande question
mais n'oublions pas que nous sommes
idleb à 40 km de la frontière turque
donc on a voilà il ya quelques dizaines
d'années ou un siècle nous étions dans
l' empire dans le califat de
constantinople et donc on était dans le
levant il n'y avait pas de frontières
donc maintenant qu'à une frontière
faisait des populations sont toujours
restés quand même très être très mobile
donc il appartient il va appartenir à
l'europe d'aider la turquie dans ses
opérations humanitaires
elle a beaucoup déjà fait à l'intérieur
de la turquie il sera peut-être possible
de faire encore des choses différentes
et aussi d'intervenir à l'intérieur de
la syrie parce que la coopération entre
turquie et l'europe est essentielle
merci beaucoup pour votre analyse gérard
espère chercheur associé à la fondation
d'études pour le moyen-orient de survie